welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and hold on to your butts because the
mad mad multiverse is coming to the mcu
soon with doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness and judging by our
first look at doctor strange's next
multiversal mask that premiered at the
end of his last multiversal best in
spider-man no way home the laws of
reality are breaking down allowing for
the craziest of possibilities and cameos
that would drive any organism that does
not like fun and exciting [ __ ]
absolutely mad and with rumored cameos
from sony spider-man and fox x-men
brewing all over icarly's internet
interesting what if i told you that
multiverse of madness could also cameo
one of the greatest threats the
fantastic four and the marvel universe
have ever faced that's right my nerd
babies there is a good chance that we
could see galactus and his origins
revealed in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness because my friends
marvel studios has secretly been hiding
their galactus plans right under our
noses the entire time this video is
brought to you by squarespace from
websites and online stores to marketing
tools and analytics squarespace is the
all-in-one platform to build a beautiful
online presence and run your business so
let's go on and speculate speculation
nation okay so remember how we got to
meet up with wrong briefly in spiderman
no way home and he seemed like he was a
little bit too preoccupied to babysit
his interns long enough to keep aunt may
and her donuts safe from willem dafoe
like why was that like what was wrong
with the wong that he needed to frosted
flake out on the homies for so long well
if you think about it before his short
run in with peter and noah home the last
mcu hero wong cross over with was chung
chi at the end of his first solo film as
dizzy plus seems to confirm in their
timeline ordering of their face poor
films and in that post-credits scene we
learn that the tan rings are sending a
powerful beacon out into space with a
signal that seems to strangely affect
every wizard that taps into that same
orange eldritch magic that chung chi's
rings glowed when he straight up murked
that dweller in darkness in the magical
land of tallow and good thing too
because that that dude sucked now we
don't know exactly which cosmic
nefarious forces out there in the
universe might have heard or felt these
signals coming from the ten rings i mean
given that shengji does seem to take
place shortly before the emergence of
tiamet in eternals there is a good
chance that the tannering's beacon could
have been what triggered the celestials
to mcu earth however i do not think that
it's just the celestials that could have
felt this energetic shift because as we
can also deduce from the events of
chongqi this energy projection from the
rings can also be felt on a multiversal
scale because remember when ying non
shong chi's badass aunt does reveal to
us that talo does not exist within the
same universe as the main mcu it is a
neighbor universe like the tobi and
andrew spiderman universes and the fox
x-men universe completely separate play
the clip john the realm of tallow
stretches far beyond the shores of our
small village we have cities that
surpass any in your universe this quote
from chiang chi's aunt about talo having
cities beyond anything in the entirety
of xiangxi's universe should not be
taken lightly because i believe that
this is marvel studios secret way of
teasing galactus's coming cosmic carnage
to the marvel cinematic universe because
the reason why tolo is called tah low is
because that this is the mcu version of
galactus home planet of tah because in
the very pages of 4 169 where the
galactus origin is first revealed
galactus himself reveals that his
paradise home planet of tah was a planet
so far advanced than any other that
there are no words to do it justice and
it's ever-changing ever ancient ever
wondrous to behold and the boy galactus
was not lying about the ancient wonder
because in addition to having amazing
technological advancements like you know
these thought spheres that the citizens
of todd used to use to travel instead of
cars which could be why the mountains of
tallow have those holes in them maybe
for thought spears to go through the
planet of tao was also home to dragons
and other weird mythical creatures much
like tallow is but chung chi was
literally teasing the coming of galactus
right under our noses well what do you
know tallow was tah on the low
[Laughter]
if 2022 is the year that you finally
start your own business squarespace is
the all-in-one platform to build a
beautiful online presence for that
business the kind of website that makes
you look and feel fortune 500 even if
you're just starting out and are more
like mom's basement 9 000. squarespace
lets you present members only gated
content connect your social media
accounts present video content and all
other cool features to give you a super
cool super functional website for your
hobby or business squarespace will even
sell you a url which is fantastic
collect the emails of interested folks
and send custom newsletters to keep them
up to date on what you're doing and all
the cool new business stuff that you are
up to head to squarespace.com for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch go
to squarespace.com new rockstars to save
10 off your first purchase of a website
or domain that's squarespace.com new
rockstars for 10 off your first purchase
of a website or domain now this is where
those floating ruins in the multiverse
of madness trailer as well as silvi
shenanigans during loki come in because
there is a possibility that these ruins
could be the multiversal ruins where the
kamatage connected tallow once stood
because remember when silly bombed
jonathan major's sacred timeline then
nothing seemingly came of it seemingly
well in the marvel comics the space
explorer galum the man galactus was
before he crunched on continents was the
first to report to everybody on his home
planet of tah that their universe was
doomed to be consumed by the multiversal
dark entity they called the black winter
a dark force that disintegrated and
killed everything in its path much like
goliath in the tva timeline destroying
eliath bombs did in the loki series with
the black winter eventually killing
everybody in the universe except for
gatlin ooh despite his desperate attempt
to flee the black winter by flying his
spaceship directly into ta's sun ends up
being turned into galactus by this
entity the black winter itself according
to a recent 2024 comic book run but this
all being said with alliance dark
multiversal energies consuming so many
timelines after sylvie's bombings we
could very well see at least the
beginnings of a potential mcu galactus
origin story in multiverse of madness
because with the mcu establishing tallow
as the main mcu's newest multiversal
neighbor with xiongchi not long after
having sylvie bombing so many of the
mcu's neighbors in loki we could very
well see the mcu's adaptation of
galactus's comic's origins as galin is
turned into a galactus as a result of
silby introducing eliath's darknesses to
the universe of tallow and also because
the super strong signal is being sent
out from the 10 rings that can be felt
on a multiversal level galactus could
make a beeline directly for mcu earth
through one of the many unstable
dimensional openings that doctor strange
seemed to be opening up in multiverse or
madness those very unstable dimensional
openings that mordor warned him about in
doctor strange 1 if he kept on abusing
the power of that time traveling green
bean of his temporal manipulations can
create branches in time
unstable dimensional openings
spatial paradoxes time loops you want to
get stuck reliving the same moment over
and over forever or never having existed
at all and this could be the very threat
that wong could have gone to address
during the events of no way home rather
than you know defend new york city and
the new york sanctum from
multi-dimensional threats like the
sinister cinco he probably had bigger
more cosmically hungrier things headed
to our planet to worry about and if
these floating ruins in the multiverse
of madness trailer are the ruins of
comtaj and kamartage is somehow linked
to all of the eldritch magic in the mcu
there could be also a chance that
strange's orange eldritch magic could
have disappeared with talos destruction
which is why strange could be leaning on
america's chavez and wanda maxima for
help because they use a different form
of energy than the magic of kamartash
but whether it's through tiny gallon or
a large man galactus i definitely do
think that tallow will be ushering in
our favorite two-eyed two-horned rhymey
purple planet eater very soon to the mcu
especially with the fantastic four on
the way and since john watch just got
his multiversal crash course with no way
home he's the perfect man to tackle some
multiversal shenanigans with galactus
i'm just saying but that is what i think
let us know what you guys think in the
comment section below you can follow me
at mastertainment if you want to see me
tweet some really weird [ __ ] but most
importantly you can follow us at new
rockstars wherever we are on social
media if you follow us on youtube please
hit that notification bell so you can
get notifications every time we upload a
video because we are always making
amazing content for you guys because we
love you guys so much i'll see you guys
later goodbye
[Music]
you